oh there's way more to this story so let
me get this straight less than 12 hours
after the detonation of an ied on the
georgia guidestones they demolished and
cleared the whole thing for safety
reasons
so instead of just roping off the area
and conducting a thorough and full
forensic investigation
of an exploded device i mean
i was deployed in iraq and when ieds go
off i mean you remember the term ied
improvised explosive device when
something that go goes off people come
out and they try to collect as much
evidence as they can you can even
collect dna from the bomb maker
themselves and try to locate uh you know
where this originated from you can even
find out you know what the explosive
type was so you can further investigate
to see where that came from as well so
when i saw on this site which is
unbelievably bizarre as it is let me
just say if you don't know what the
georgia guide zones are
get ready to be creeped out because it's
actually surprising just how many people
have never seen or heard of these things
before
and if you're not familiar i will fill
you in
so first of all let's be clear this was
created in 1980 and the people
whoever they were that finance this are
still a mystery it is unknown to the
public who put the money behind to have
this constructed
however there are some suspicions for
example ted turner grew up in this area
which by the way
this area i mean this thing is in
practically the middle of nowhere it's
in it's in georgia at a place that
nobody goes through which is one reason
why people suspect that ted turner could
have been involved and if you're not
familiar ted turner is the founder of
cnn which is of course the most trusted
name in news and if it was up to me
let's be real
i'd have cnn be the the lead news
producer for the entire milky way galaxy
if it was up to me outstanding source of
information that has never been wrong
about anything
not even on
by accident oh that's hard to say anyway
furthermore so we don't know so that's
interesting and some people will say
that these stones are benign come on
this is just something that some rich
guy did in the event that there was some
cataclysmic event and this is a guidance
on how humanity should proceed forward
for the best
wishes of not just mankind but planet
earth itself well let me say this
anything that involves a plan for all of
humanity
that's done in secrecy
is not for your benefit
if these stones were benign and a good
thing there would be no secrecy
now speaking of secrets here's something
else we don't know which is what is in
the buried time capsule that's six feet
under this monument
that's right i don't know
if they're going to exhume this thing or
not
but i and the rest of the world
should be able to see what this is
because it could be very telling it
could lead to answers on who did this in
the first place or
god who knows what else all i know is
that i want to know what's in this and
everyone should get behind two things
here which is identifying who created
this in the first place and what's in
that damn time capsule
now
many people refer to this as the new
world order monument or a monument for
globalism and it surely is because this
thing favored a one-world government it
favored marxism i.e societal mandates
and control over the individual
it favored eugenics like what the like
are you serious you know the stuff that
the nazis were into like controlling who
breeds and stuff like that like that's
not a good thing ever it's so wrong on
so many levels but let me just keep
going for a second because
it even favored a mass depopulation of
planet earth now let me let me be clear
these stones were in the built in the
context of post cataclysm and saying hey
maintain
the whole population of the world to 500
million
but right now we're at nearly 7.9
billion
which means that that would be a
reduction of nearly 94
of the population that's alive today in
fact that would be 15
out of 16 people ceasing to exist
you know a lot of people are talking
right now about depopulation that
there's too many people on planet earth
and everything else and we're destroying
it
um
but
i'm sorry i don't know what the number
might be that would be best for humans
on earth but to suggest that there's
like
that it should be reduced by 94 seems
extreme to me but let me keep going
this thing in fact you know let me just
read off real quick all 10 of them okay
so maintain humanity under 500 million
in perpetual balance with nature okay
guide reproduction wisely improving
fitness and diversity okay that is
pretty talk for eugenics that is another
word saying like certain people should
not have kids well who's to say that and
going back to the 500 million point
who's to say how many who can have
children and how many that is no one's
right but their own and guys i agree if
you drive by some you know some trailer
park and someone's got 10 kids and all
this and like we know that's not a great
thing right
but what are you gonna do about it put
him in put mommy and daddy in jail
you know shoot him what are you gonna do
no one has a right but them okay um let
me just keep going though so number
three unite humanity with a living new
language now there's pros and cons to
this i think that one of the problems in
the world is that we don't speak the
same language and we don't understand
where people are coming from i see the
same thing with the whole russian
thing today it's like guys the russians
are our friends like have you ever known
russians they're cool and the only
reason why we have nothing seemingly
nothing in common and no connection is
because our languages are so vastly
different but i digress um oh let me
actually just say that languages
multiple languages are a good thing it's
one thing that makes the human race so
interesting and culture and world travel
so fun but
anyway
number four rule passion faith tradition
in all things with tempered reason
fair enough
five protect people and nations with
fair laws and just courts well oh my god
that sounds wonderful i agree
six let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court
see that's the thing that's where this
new world order in world government
becomes a thing because slippery slope
is no
it's not just some some
what's the word for it i'm thinking of
cliche no like there's a slippery slope
to everything and i'm sorry a world
court no like within reason of course
like the nuremberg trials those are
wonderful
um but when it comes to a world court it
seemingly it seems to me that there's a
call consolidation of power happening
right now and that's why i i get a
little disturbed with these
these stones but let me keep going
number seven avoid petty laws and
useless officials well oh my god i
probably agree with this above all else
um because
my yeah big government right that's what
that represents and it's saying that big
government's not a great thing so okay
cool i agree with that as well
number eight um balance personal rights
with social duties uh
stop hold the brakes right there what
the hell no no no no no no that is
marxism that is a i mean it sounds so
nice balanced personal rights or social
duties okay you know hey for a community
and a society we gotta
you know come together and do things you
know as one
there's some truth to that but then
there's this fine line where it becomes
marxism which is communism and that is
not a good thing historically at all
whatsoever who am i case in point uh the
maoist in china the soviets of russia
pol pot and cambodia oh it was it oh my
god i forgot this whole hitler thing
that went on but never mind that that's
old news right guys when you when you
have the governing body controlling the
individual
that is a bad thing and that's exactly
what that's getting at
um let me keep going nine prize truth
beauty love see harmony with the
infinite
great that sounds wonderful that that
could be a philosophy conversation in
itself
but number 10 be not a cancer on the
earth leave room for nature leave room
for nature
see
there's two ways of looking at this one
of which is like well that's a good
thing you're right leave room for nature
let's not be a cancer on this earth
which we are but there's another way of
looking at it where people start playing
around being like yeah
there's too much not enough room for
nature you know at 7.9 billion
that's a bit too much here let's get
down to 500 million
now again i know people right now are
gonna interrupt and be like hey they're
not these stones do not say anything
about reducing population
okay i understand that but let me be
clear if there was a cataclysmic event
the last thing humanity would need would
be a one world government eugenics
population control
or or marxism and society as a whole
controlling the individual in the last
two years should be a real wake-up call
for people on what happens when you have
a small number of people controlling the
global population and and let me say
something else i don't know if you're
paying attention to what's happening in
the world involving a global famine the
likes of which haven't been seen in our
lifetimes and is so unnecessary in 2022.
look at the riots happening in the
netherlands france spain italy um and
elsewhere um sri lanka like go look this
up now because this ties into my last
few videos when i've been sounding alarm
saying guys something is afoot here
something bad is happening it's not an
accident people are making it happen and
it's completely preventable and
unnecessary but where things stand right
now things are standing to get ugly and
again i've said it before i'll say it
again i don't want to be the doomsday
guy but someone's got to say it because
not enough people are and we this world
is what we make of it
and
it's only going to be through waking up
and informing enough people to what's
going on to have any effect and change
whatsoever so look up those food
shortages where they're shutting down
farmers and saying you can't plant it
has to do with fertilizer and all this
stuff and you know
keeping things green and clean and
everything for planet earth yeah sounds
great but you know what
if if that was the simple explanation
then why is this catching everyone with
their pants down nobody saw this coming
it's like it's like came out of the
woodwork
and why is it that most people don't
even know about it i've chatted with
friends and family that have no idea
about these riots across the world that
should be front page headline that
farmers are rioting against
police are shooting at farmer tractors
what in like in the midst of an energy
crisis and global famine uh and a food
shortage which is only going to escalate
from here on out and when i said it
before that these things weren't an
accident you see why because you're
stopping people from farming they're
culling animals and everything else so
um
now let me let me just close this up um
you know because i want to move on to my
other stuff but like uh
let's be clear guys some people anyone
saying that these stones are benign and
there's some goodness to them well guess
what when the when the cataclysm happens
well then you're basically forfeiting
your rights to someone to anyone right
that's like me saying like hey all right
well since you're all for this globalism
this marxism and these eugenics and
everything that means that jimmy or
someone else
gets to tell you what exactly what
you're going to be doing
post apocalypse right cataclysm no no
that's not good and and and to anyone
that's trying to defend these stones i
think you guys need to dig into this
where they came from he said they were
created by rc christian well look into
who that really is google rc christian
you'll see that is the founder or a
pseudonym because it's declared as a
pseudonym so not even the pearl person's
name and they chose the founder of the
rosicrucian secret society
guys that's how you know this stuff is
is not on the up and up
like there why would this secretive
group of people
choose the
founder of a
dark sided secret society
as the
movement to proceed forward in a new
global era and no no no no no no and
again like i said anything done in
secrecy especially that involves all of
humanity is not benign if there was if
this was good and benign and nothing to
worry about there would be no need for
secrecy it'd be a global conversation
and everything would be fine but when
you do things behind other people's
backs that's when you know something's
up there is there
we've been fed far too there are so many
lies in this world it's you can make
your head spin
and how are things going things are as
crazier than ever and it seems to be
escalating
so i would argue that the last thing we
need is any more secrecy and what we
need is the truth so with that said you
should ask yourselves why they decided
to bulldoze this site so quick without
enough time to do a thorough forensic
investigation
we need to find out what's in the time
capsule and we need to find out who
created this site originally because
if there's nothing bad then
this is harmless no big deal just tell
us the truth and all will be well right
my name is jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright insight leave a comment
share this video and share your thoughts
on what you think about the things in
this the information shared in this
video but i'm going to wrap it up here
and move on to the next topic i love you
all see you again real soon take care